Seção 6 de Dom Casmurro.
Esta é uma gravação LibriVox. Todas as gravações LibriVox estão em domínio público. Para mais informações, ou para ser um voluntário, por favor visite: librivox.org. Gravado por Raquel Morais.
Dom Casmurro, de Machado de Assis. Seção 6.
Capítulo 26. As leis são belas. Pela cara de José Dias passou algo parecido com o reflexo de uma ideia, uma ideia que o alegrou extraordinariamente. Calou-se alguns instantes; eu tinha os olhos nele; ele voltara os seus para o lado da barra, como se insistisse.
— É tarde, disse ele. Mas, para lhe provar que não há falta de vontade, irei falar a sua mãe. Não prometo vencer, mas lutar; trabalharei com alma. Deveras, não quer ser padre? As leis são belas, meu querido; pode ir a São Paulo, a Pernambuco, ou ainda mais longe; há boas universidades por esse mundo fora. Vá para as leis, se tal é a sua vocação; vou falar a Dona Glória. Mas não conte só comigo; fale também com seu tio.
— Hei de falar. — Pegue-se também com Deus, com Deus e a Virgem Santíssima, concluiu apontando para o céu.
O céu estava meio enfarruscado; no ar, perto da praia, grandes pássaros negros faziam giros, a voaçassem ou pairando, e desciam a roçar os pés na água e tornavam a erguer-se, para descer novamente. Mas nem as sombras do céu, nem as danças fantásticas dos pássaros me desviavam o espírito do meu interlocutor. Depois de lhe responder que sim, emendei-me:
— Deus fará o que o senhor quiser. — Não blasfeme! Deus é dono de tudo; ele é, só por si, a terra e o céu, o passado, o presente e o futuro. Peça-lhe a sua felicidade, que eu não faço outra coisa. Uma vez que você não pode ser padre e prefere as leis, as leis são belas, sem desfazeres na teologia, que é melhor que tudo, como a vida eclesiástica é a mais santa. Porque não há de ir estudar leis fora daqui? Melhor é ir logo para alguma universidade, e ao mesmo tempo que estuda, viaja. Poderemos ir juntos; veremos as terras estrangeiras, ouviremos inglês, francês, italiano, espanhol, russo e até sueco. Dona Glória, provavelmente, não poderá acompanhá-lo; ainda que possa e vá, não quererá guiar os negócios, papéis, matrículas, e cuidar de hospedarias, e andar com você de um lado para outro... Oh, as leis são belíssimas!
— Está dito, pede a mamãe que não me meta no seminário? — Pedir, peço; mas pedir não é alcançar. Anjo do meu coração, se vontade de servir é poder de mandar, estamos aqui, estamos a bordo! Ali! você não imagina o que é a Europa... Oh, a Europa!
Levantou a perna e fez uma pirueta. Uma das suas ambições era tornar à Europa; falava dela muitas vezes, sem acabar de tentar minha mãe nem o Tio Cosme, por mais que louvasse os ares e as belezas. Não contava com esta possibilidade de ir comigo e lá ficar durante a eternidade dos meus estudos. "Estamos a bordo, Bentinho, estamos a bordo!"
Capítulo 27. Ao portão. Ao portão do Passeio um mendigo estendeu-nos a mão. José Dias passou adiante, mas eu, pensei em Capitu e no seminário, tirei dois vinténs do bolso e dei-os ao mendigo. Este beijou a moeda. Eu pedi-lhe que rogasse a Deus por mi, a fim de que eu pudesse satisfazer todos os meus desejos.
— Sim, meu devoto. — Chamo-me Bento, acrescentei para esclarecê-lo.
Capítulo 28. Na rua. José Dias ia tão contente que trocou o homem dos momentos graves, como era a rua, pelo homem dobradiço e inquieto. Mexia-se todo, falava de tudo, fazia-me parar a cada passo diante de um mostrador ou de um cartaz de teatro; contava-me o enredo de algumas peças, recitava monólogos em verso; fez os recados todos, pagou contas, recebeu aluguéis de casa; para si comprou um vigésimo de loteria. Afinal o homem teso rendeu o flexível, e passou a falar pausado, com superlativos.
Não vi que a mudança era natural, temi que houvesse mudado a resolução assentada, e entrei a tratá-lo com palavras e gestos carinhosos até entrarmos no ônibus.
Capítulo 29. O Imperador. Em caminho encontramos o Imperador, que vinha da Escola de Medicina. O ônibus em que íamos parou, como todos os veículos. Os passageiros desceram à rua e tiraram o chapéu até que o coche imperial passasse. Quando tornei ao meu lugar, trazia uma ideia fantástica, a ideia de ir ter com o Imperador, contar-lhe tudo, pedir-lhe a intervenção. Não confiaria esta ideia a Capitu. "Sua Majestade pedindo, mamãe cede", pensei comigo. Vi-o então, o Imperador, escutando-me, refletindo, e acabando por dizer que sim, que iria falar a minha mãe. Eu beijava-lhe a mão com lágrimas; e logo me achei em casa, à espera, até que ouvi os batedores e o piquete de cavalaria: "É o Imperador! É o Imperador!" Toda a gente chegava às janelas para vê-lo passar, mas não passava, o coche imperial parava à nossa porta, o Imperador apeava-se e entrava. Grande alvoroço na vizinhança: "O Imperador entrou em casa de Dona Glória! Que será? Que não será?" A nossa família saía a recebê-lo; minha mãe era a primeira que lhe beijava a mão. Então o Imperador, todo risonho, sem entrar na sala ou entrando — não me lembra bem, os sonhos são muita vez confusos —, pedia a minha mãe que não me fizesse padre, e ela, lisonjeada e obediente, prometia que não.
— A medicina, porque lhe não manda ensinar medicina? — Uma vez que é do agrado de Vossa Majestade... — Mande ensinar-lhe medicina; é uma bonita carreira, e nós temos aqui bons professores. Nunca foi à nossa escola? É uma bela escola; já temos médicos de primeira ordem, que podem ombrear com os melhores de outras terras. A medicina é uma grande ciência; basta só isto de dar saúde aos outros, conhecer as moléstias, combatê-las, vencê-las. A senhora mesma há de ter visto milagres. O marido morreu, mas a doença era fatal, e ele não tinha cuidado em si. É uma bonita carreira, mande-o para a nossa escola, faça isso por mim, sim? Você quer, Bentinho? Minha mãe querendo... "Quero, meu filho, Sua Majestade manda."
Então o Imperador dava outra vez a mão a beijar e saía, acompanhado de todos nós, à rua cheia de gente, as janelas atopetadas, e um silêncio de assombro. O Imperador entrava no coche, inclinava-se, e fazia um gesto de adeus, dizendo ainda:
— A medicina, a nossa escola.
E o coche partia entre invejas e agradecimentos. Tudo isto vi e ouvi. Não, a imaginação de Ariosto não é mais fértil que a das crianças e dos namorados, nem a visão do impossível precisa mais que de um recanto de ônibus. Consolei-me por instantes, digamos minutos, até destruir-se o plano e voltar-me para as caras sem sonhos dos meus companheiros.
Capítulo 30. O Santíssimo. — Parece que vai sair o Santíssimo, disse alguém no ônibus. Ouço um sino. — É, creio que é um Santo Antônio dos Pobres. Pare, senhor recebedor.
O recebedor das passagens puxou a correia que ia ter ao braço do cocheiro, o ônibus parou, e o homem desceu. José Dias deu duas voltas rápidas à cabeça, pegou-me pelo braço, e fez-me descer consigo; iríamos também acompanhar o Santíssimo.
Efetivamente, o sino chamava os fiéis àquele serviço da última hora. Já havia algumas pessoas na sacristia. Era primeira vez que me achava em momento tão grave. Obedeci, a princípio constrangido, mas logo depois satisfeito, menos pela caridade do serviço que por me dar um ofício de homem. Quando o sacristão começou a distribuir as opas, entrou um sujeito esbaforido. Era o meu vizinho Pádua, que também ia acompanhar o Santíssimo. Deu conosco, veio cumprimentar-nos. José Dias fez um gesto de aborrecido e apenas lhe respondeu com uma palavra seca, olhando para o Pádua, que lavava as mãos. Depois, como Pádua falasse ao sacristão, baixinho, aproximou-se deles; eu fiz a mesma cousa.
Pádua solicitava ao sacristão uma das varas do pálio. José Dias pediu uma para si.
— Há só uma disponível, disse o sacristão. — Pois essa, disse José Dias. — Mas eu tinha pedido primeiro, aventurou Pádua. — Pediu primeiro, mas entrou tarde, retorquiu José Dias. Eu já cá estava.
Pádua, apesar do medo que tinha ao outro, teimava em querer a vara; tudo isto em voz baixa e surda. O sacristão achou meio de conciliar a rivalidade, tomando a si obter de um dos outros seguradores do pálio que cedesse a vara ao Pádua, conhecido na paróquia, como José Dias. Assim fez, mas José Dias transtornou ainda esta combinação:
— Não, uma vez que tínhamos outra vara disponível, pedia-a para mim, jovem seminarista, a quem esta distinção cabia mais diretamente.
Pádua ficou pálido como as tochas; era pôr à prova o coração de um pai. O sacristão, que me conhecia de me ver ali com minha mãe aos domingos, perguntou de curioso se eu era deveras seminarista.
— Ainda não, mas vai sê-lo, respondeu José Dias, piscando o olho esquerdo para mim, que, apesar do aviso, fiquei zangado.
— Bem, cedo ao nosso Bentinho, suspirou o pai de Capitu, pela minha parte, conceder-lhe a vara.
Lembrou-me que ele costumava acompanhar o Santíssimo Sacramento aos moribundos, levando uma tocha, mas que a última vez conseguira uma vara do pálio. A distinção especial do pálio vinha de cobrir o vigário e o sacramento; para a tocha qualquer pessoa servia. Foi ele mesmo que me contou e explicou isto, cheio de uma glória pia e risonha.
Opas enfiadas, tochas distribuídas e acesas, padre e cibório prontos, o sacristão, de opo e campainha nas mãos, saiu o préstito à rua. Quando me vi com uma das varas passando pelos fiéis que se ajoelhavam, fiquei comovido. Pádua roía a tocha amargamente. É uma metáfora, não acho outra forma mais viva de dizer a dor e a humilhação do meu vizinho. De resto, não pude mirá-lo por muito tempo, nem ao agregado, que paralelamente a mim erguia a cabeça com ar de ele próprio o Deus dos Exércitos. Felizmente a casa era perto, na Rua do Senado. A enferma era uma senhora viúva, tísica, tinha uma filha de quinze ou dezesseis anos, que estava chorando à porta do quarto. A moça não era formosa, talvez nem tivesse graça; os cabelos caíam despenteados, e as lágrimas faziam-lhe encarquilhar os olhos. Não obstante, o total falava e cativava o coração. O vigário confessou a doente, deu-lhe a comunhão e os santos óleos. O pranto da moça redobrou tanto que senti os meus olhos molhados e fugi; vim para perto de uma janela. Pobre criatura! A dor era comunicativa em si mesma; complicada da lembrança de minha mãe, doeu-me mais, e quando enfim pensei em Capitu, senti um ímpeto de soluçar também. Enfiei pelo corredor e ouvi alguém dizer-me: "Não chore assim."
A imagem de Capitu ia comigo, e a minha imaginação, assim como lhe atribuíra lágrimas há pouco, assim lhe encheu a boca de riso agora; vi-a escrever no muro, falar-me, andar à volta com os braços no ar; ouvi distintamente o meu nome, de uma doçura que me embriagou, e a voz era dela. As tochas acesas, tão lúgubres na ocasião, tinham-me ares de um lustre nupcial. Que era lustre nupcial? Não sei; era alguma cousa contrária à morte, e não vejo outra mais que bodas.
Fim da seção 6. Gravado por Raquel Morais.